so this article that Elizabeth Bruns
that he wrote said that Iggy Pop
mentioned that if he had to live off of
his royalties he would have to 10 bar
between sets basically knowing that he's
still making films even if you knew you
had to take side jobs doing commercials
music things like that you assisting him
or you doing your own projects is that
something that you're willing to succumb
to to make something that you're so
passionate that you're willing to spend
so much time on I mean fortunately for
us we've never had the opportunity to
put golden handcuffs on ourselves we
live extremely simply and frugally and
so that's never I think it's much harder
for guys to fall down the money trees
and want to climb up it if that makes
sense like a guy like Iggy Pop and I you
know I don't know him personally don't
know his lifestyle but I can only guess
you know came with a nice car in house
and and all of these things and so it's
a lot harder to adjust to giving that up
then it would be to adjust to the idea
that this may never be lucrative on a
broader level and I'm always going to be
behind whatever leaps out of jaemin's
heart and mind so whatever that but it's
true and I guess the point is not to
make a our goal I guess has never been
to make money and we do have to do all
those things we do take we do take
commercial work we do take side jobs and
I think that's we're terrible bartenders
we are yes
Shaymin just got fired from the movie
theater yeah I think that's the fame and
money should not ultimately be the goal
of doing this and it's really not for us
so I think that that's um yeah yeah and
I think in a way it's kind of good I
mean I think it's I don't think
struggling has ever been a bad thing for
artists I say that at this moment I will
not be saying that in another moment but
uh but I do think that I do think that
that's not necessarily a bad thing I
mean I think
I mean there's always struggle Andy and
in this business but I do think that it
does help weed out people who really
their hearts are not in it you know and
I think you it's just you really
shouldn't be doing this unless you
really are passionate about it and you
know at that point it isn't about the
money and it's I mean and don't get me
wrong it's really really hard to survive
and that's a really critical thing and
trying to figure out that balances we
all know but yeah that's all I got
you